on va revenir sur l'amour et dans le Pr
cétait hier soir sur M6 qui a terminé
première des audiences cette émission
4,1 million de téléspectateurs CTA F1
qui a pas marché hier avec super papa je
sais pas ce que
c'était ah d'accord
merde ah merde les deux je les aime bien
ah mais mal programmé pas le lundi pas
le lundi je suis désolé le jeudi oui pas
le lundi bon allez on va revenir sur
l'amour et dans le
Pr bah c'est pas mal c'est pas mal 4
million de téléspectateurs ça commence à
à faire alors c'était donc la première
partie du bilan de la saison ça a
beaucoup fait réagir sur les réseaux et
dans un instant on va voir vous savez
que chaque semaine tous les mardis on
fait un peu un queon qu'il devenu dans
fr on aime bien on aura Vincent Vincent
vous rappelez de Vincent ah oui ou ah le
cheval tréquestre oua oua Vincent cheval
et ben Vincent c'est pas le cheval hein
c'est le gars à
côté on va pas accueillir le cheval i on
va pas mettre le cheval là bande de con
je crois que le cheval il va avoir les
exts à faire tu es con tu es con comme
une pendule non mais c'est pas possible
non mais VO s rigoler bon allez on vair
sur hier alors il y avit je- le sé
pendant son voyage avec sa prétendante
Maria il s'est pas vraiment comporté
comme
[Musique]
une
magnif vre massage est terminé pour
aujourd'ui une petite jouissance je me
suis retrouvé un peu au au 7e ciel je su
contente doêre heure V
mar i vos mains oh ah ça y est tu as
fini tu as aimé il y a pas que le dos
qui m'a détendu il y a un truc qui s'est
tendu mais il y a un truc qui s'est
détendu Vincent merci d'être là on va
commencer cette nou on va commmenter
cette nouvelle saison avec nous ça va
mon Vincent ben grand plaisir merci ça
va content de te voir saison 16 je me
rappelle très bien de toi et toi tu
avais tuavais pas chômé toi ah bon à ce
po là
comment rappelle de toi si j'étais sage
oh tu étais pas venu pour planter des
des arbustes
euh c'est vrai je me rappelle tu avais
retenu deux prétendantes Afsa et Natasa
oui ouais
ouis ouais était très jolie beau casting
Sartek ça va ça va on parler dans un
instant regarde rappelle-toi de
ça h ça oui non ça va ça va c'est
descend là ah tu es beau aussi c'est
vrai merci oui c'est très très joli
merci c'est gentil alors je vu que tu
étais une paysane des montagnes
explique-moi parce que là alors paysane
des montagnes là je te vois comme ça tu
fais pas trop paysan classe
paysan Natacha j'avais un petit peur
peur de ça on s'arrête un peu aux
apparences dans ma vie de tous les jours
je je suis pas comme ça je suis à la
ferme moi j'ai un petit frère qui a des
brebis aussi du mal quand je te vois
comme ça dira bon
quoi
ah j'aime bien Vincent alors bon tu
avais choisi tu avais choisi Natacha
c'est ça et quand tu as dit àsa que en
fait tu avais choisi Natacha ça c'était
pas ouf ah ben c'était pas la même
ambiance he forcément ouais c'est vrai
que l'ambiance tout de suite est
redescendu le soir quand elle est parti
Afsa Natacha me dit ce soir c'est Noël
pour moi ah ouais
pour
Bou
[Applaudissements]
plus fort que lui j'ai même j'ai les
même que Jean-Michel mer c'est pas bon
c'est ah ouais bon parce que tout de
suite moi aussi je me suis dit il a dû
sortir des boules à la guirlande mais et
donc et donc et donc elle a pris ses cl
et ses claqu elle est partie et ouais is
je me rappelle donc donc ça c'est fait
avec Natacha sauf que quand tu arrives
au bilan en fait toi euh il y a eu un
regardez un délire en
fait bravo toi attention à toi non mais
attention quand
mêmee mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
dame avec des cheveux des gambes qui est
cette personne c'est ma surprise comment
tu t'appelles Justin bon alors nous la
dernière je suis désolée on va être
obligé de raconter quand même tout ce
qui s'est passé avant d'en arriver à
toi par que jusqu'à aujourd'hui il y a
pas de Justine
voilà
en fait en fait tu es tu étais plus avec
Natacha tuas t'as ramené Justine en fait
non ben parce qu'en fait si tu veux
quand l'émission se finit il y a pas mal
de temps encore combien de temps oh ben
c'est quelques mois hein c'est c'est
c'est pas mal quand même pas de ma
gueule quand même tuexpliqueras ça au
juge donc ouais et et donc tu étais avec
Justine mais en fait je crois savoir
qu'après tu étais avec une certaine
Candice c'est ça ah ou je suis tu es
toujours avec Candice non je reste à peu
près UN1 avec Justine cette demoiselle
Justine Justine ça s'appelle Justine
ouais voilà ouais fais gaffe avec les
pour les prénoms j'ai l'impression que
on est en train de s'embrouiller et ça
fait un an et demi que cand je suis avec
tuas connu où je l'ai connu ben tu sais
après sur les réseau voilà la la vie la
vie continue hein c'est pas l'écran
c'est un tout petit morceau mais bon et
là là tu es bien là tu es bien là là je
suis très bien ça va impeccable un an et
demi ça commence à faire ben ouais c'est
pas mal hein donc tu penses que ça va
crois je vais changer
non non non tu penses là c'est la c'est
la bonne là ah ouais peut-être oui ou
oui après c'est c'est le début hein
c'est pas c'est début c'est déb un an et
demi pourqui ça fait beaucoup elle
habite à côté de chez toi elle habite à
côté de chez toi maintenant elle habite
avec moi oui depuis longtemps ou ah
ouais ah bon délire quoi bah un conseil
faut pas lui dire peut-être hein ouais
peut-être peut-être sur quoi bah là elle
vous regarde je suppose oui bah faut pas
lui dire peut-être bah après je pas dans
une boule de cristal non plus oui mais
il faut lui faire croire en minimum
faire croire
pas bien ça non non il faut être honnête
mais en fait ça se passe très bien on a
des on a beaucoup de de choses en commun
avec les chevaux et tout et ah oua et
c'est professionnel non non c'est bien
professionnel professionnel mais elle
est tombée sous votre charme grâce à
l'amour et dans le prê parce qu'elle
vous a vu elle vous a repéré comme ça
alors elle m'a vu oui forcément à la
télé mais après elle me connaissait de
mes spectacles avant ok alors tuas tu
regardes tu continues à regarder laamour
et dans le prix ou pas oui je regarde tu
as regardé hier ouais tu as vu Jean-Paul
Jean-Paul et Maria ils se sont dit qu'
qu'il voulait se quitter sauf qu'ils se
sont dit au restaurant qu' n' n était
qu'à l'entrée la suite c'est un
Jean-Paul en roue libre qui va en fait
Péchot tout ce qui bouge était lâché le
gar lâché
total je suis content de finir cette
cette
histoire tu me conviens ple voilà il
disait que c'était une femme comme vous
qui lui fallait ah bah Maria elle est
pas très loin hein oui mais on est en
rupture là quel dommage que vous
m'annonciez ça dans ce restaurant si
romantique bah oui je m'excuse moi les
goujas c'est bon j'en avais jamais
rencontré un mais j'en ai rencontré un
ah bon ben donc quand même vous avez un
petit peu d'amertume là vous AZ biener
quoi regarde pas dans mes yeux ah je
regarde pas dans les yeux non non non
non mais alors je vais vous raconter moi
je suis marié Mar je te quitte pour
toujours
tant mieux d'accord on est bien d'accord
je suis d'accord bon bon on a passé une
bonne soirée une excellente
soirée ah il y va il a dit je démon tu
m'en je m'en Ouffe alors cette année
c'est un carnage et pas que pour
Jean-Paul si on a vu des des débuts de
coupe se former finalement au moment du
bilan tous ceux qu'on a suivi hier Anaïs
Julien Olivier Roméo et Jean-Paul se
retrouvent tous ces libres
regardez mais pourquoi es-tu toute seule
c'est fini avec Thomas oui
ou c'était un peu un naufrage oui oui
oui tu t'es pas intéressé à elle ouais
peut-être je enfin je me suis pas rendu
compte de ça j'avais pas les sentiments
et je pouvais pas lui dire ce que je
pensais pas quand ça s'est fini avec
avec Sophie oui tu lu dit qu'elle était
grosse et vieille voilà
donc c'est vrai que là ça été une é
tombe oui c'est un fiasco total
effectivement ça arrive oui mais le
problème c'est que comme rien ne marche
on a vraiment l'impression qu'ils sont
pas venus pour trouver l'amour ou mais
bon ça arrive ça
arrive zéro zéro hier vous rendez compte
trve voilà je trouve au contraire que ça
montre effectivement c'est des vrais
histoires avec des vrais gens et que ça
peut marcher ou pas marcher on a eu des
bébés et des mariage pendant des tas
d'années donc là si pour une fois ça
marche moins c'est que ça trouve que
justement c' des vrais trucs avant tu
vois ah oui c'est que en vrai voilà ça
peut pas toujours marcher qu'est-ce tu
en pens non mais c'est la vraie vie
après moi je suis personne pour juger
les autres et après voilà c'est ils
essayent je pense qu'ils sont ils sont
tous sincères honnêtes je les ai suivi
un petit peu cette année c'est des gens
c'est des vrais gens quoi he c'est pas
il y a pas pas un scénario ou des choses
que vous pourvez imaginer non non c'est
c'est la vraie vie alors ça se met
ensemble ça sépare mais bon c'est c'est
comme ça tous les jours hein alors le
point positif de la soirée c'est David
un agriculteur qui n'avait pas reçu de
lettre mais surprise lors du bilan il
reçoit une lettre et même un rendez-vous
avec une prof des écoles alsaciennes une
séquence qui a beaucoup aimu les
téléspectateurs regardez comment tu te
sens bah déçu sûrement oui par que j'ai
pasire des lettres mais ça viendra
peut-être oui B il faut toujours
respérer dans la vie prise pour toi
ah
ah une lettre H oui si tu vas la
rencontrer dans quelques minutes
he
Karen ben David je trouve que tu as des
Jux hein merci beaucoup direct il
l'attaque
merci toi aussi tu es es
[Musique]
voilà il est intimidé
ma mais non mais c'est beau quand même B
bien sûr que c'est beau bah oui c'est
beau toi tu es heureux là maintenant là
tu es content très heureux très bien
ouais tu kiffes avec Candice ouais je
pas plein de projet je prépare mes
spectacles chos avec les chevx Ch oui
j'aime bien ça tuas pas suivi tes fiches
alors la
vérité tu débordé là pas que j'ai pas
mal de ta c'est important que tu sois
mais bon là tu vois j'ai pas mal de
trucs qui arrive là j'ai j'ai l'imam là
qui arrive là Abd al Mamoun là dans 2
minutes tes spectacles de
chevaux ma prioritémi te dire
ça te dire
ça voilà moi je dis toujours les choses
Vincent donc je suis content de te voir
et voilà je suis très content que tu
sois venuout tu reviens nous voir quand
tu veux AC grand plaisir mer je te
souhaite beaucoup de bonheur avec
QUANDICE merci c'est très gentil
attention quand même temps
ça va c'est bien là te fout pas de ma
gueule tu reviens n voir quand tu veux
en tout cas tu viendras faire la promo
pour tes
spectacles plaisir franchement tu seras
toujours je te j j'adore ça les Ch ah
EV bien sû je
monte bien voir Provence viens mon o toi
tu es où à côé de
province frère je suis là là-bas tout le
temps ben je vais venir ben viens bah je
vais venir je te dis je suis là je suis
là tout le temps même tu me fais monter
un poné même
heorte quoi je suis là t'inquiète pas